[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUFENG GUO: What
does it take to build
a custom object recognition
mobile app starting
from raw data?
We'll find out on this episode
of "Cloud AI Adventures."
Today, we're joined by
Sara Robinson, a developer
advocate on the team who also
focuses on machine learning.
She created an app
that recognizes
pictures of Taylor Swift.
And she joins me
today in the studio
to discuss how she
accomplished it.
Welcome, Sara.
Thanks for joining me.
SARA ROBINSON: Thanks for
having me-- super excited
to be on "AI Adventures."
YUFENG GUO: So you wrote a
sensational medium article
that I've got open here about
your Swift Detector, which
kind of showcases
end-to-end machine learning,
from gathering and
pre-processing the data,
to training and serving from
Cloud Machine Learning Engine.
And there's even Firebase
and an iPhone app in the mix.
SARA ROBINSON: Lots
of different tools.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah, definitely.
It's super amazing.
What inspired this project?
SARA ROBINSON: So
I'd seen a couple
of other blog posts on the
TensorFlow Object Detection
API.
And I'd been wanting to try it.
Out these blog post had
things like detecting
pets, whether there is a
cat or a dog in an image.
I saw another one about
detecting raccoons.
YUFENG GUO: Oh, wow.
SARA ROBINSON: So
then I thought,
I wanted to try it on my
own with some training
that I found.
And the easiest
thing I thought of
was to just look
at my Google Photos
and find all the
pictures of myself
to train a model to recognize
me-- had lots of selfies.
I had enough training data.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah, and
that search function
on Google Photos, super helpful.
SARA ROBINSON:
It's pretty great.
So I trained that model locally.
It works pretty well.
But I wanted to build
an end-to-end demo.
And I know a little
bit of Swift.
So I thought would be cool if
I built a iOS client to make
a prediction request against
my model, which made me think,
why don't I built a model
to detect Taylor Swift?
Because why not?
YUFENG GUO: Swift with Swift--
perfect.
So it looks like here you're
using the TensorFlow Object
Detection API to find Taylor
Swift in these pictures.
Can you talk a little
bit about what that is,
and what was it like to use it?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, sure.
So the Object Detection
API is some utilities
that make it easier to
recognize objects in an image.
So rather than just
classifying an image
as this image has
a cat in it, it'll
return bounding boxes of where
that object is in a image.
And to do that, it's
using a technique
called transfer learning, which
utilizes a model that's already
been trained on a
similar classification
task using millions
and millions of images.
And then what I do as a
developer using Object
Detection API is I
take that checkpoints
of the second to
last layer of that
model that's been trained
on millions of images.
And then I update
it with my own data,
so that I don't need
to start from scratch.
So I didn't have time
to label millions
of images of Taylor Swift.
YUFENG GUO: Though I'm sure you
wouldn't have minded, right?
SARA ROBINSON: I
wouldn't have minded
YUFENG GUO: Going through
all those pictures, yeah.
SARA ROBINSON: So I just
needed to use a smaller
set of training data to update
the final layer of that model.
YUFENG GUO: It's fantastic
that you can kind of stand
on the shoulders of giants--
all the work and all
the training that's
already been done
on these models.
SARA ROBINSON: That's one of
the great things about transfer
learning.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah.
So was the training kind
of quicker, as a result,
because you didn't have to
go through as many images?
SARA ROBINSON:
Mm-hmm, much faster.
So instead of taking maybe days,
it took just a couple of hours.
YUFENG GUO: Fantastic, awesome.
And then so actually
doing the work that--
I guess you would have had
to somehow get the images,
and do any pre-processing
required to have the TensorFlow
Object Detection API kind of
consume those images, what
formatting you needed to do, and
then actually run the training.
SARA ROBINSON: Mm-hmm.
So the Object Detection
API requires your images
be in what's called
a TFRecord format--
YUFENG GUO: TFRecord, OK.
SARA ROBINSON: And to
get them in that format,
I converted my images to
what's called the Pascal VOC
format, which is just one
format you can choose from.
It stands for Visual
Object Classification.
And what that is is
that's an XML file.
So I take all my images and
I generate this XML file,
which gives me details on
the bounding box of where
the object is.
YUFENG GUO: So that's
what's in the XML.
It's just kind of coordinates
here of the boxes themselves.
SARA ROBINSON: Mm-hmm.
So it has the x,y coordinates of
where my object is is an image.
And then it just has
the label associated
with that bounding box.
In this case, I just had
one label, Taylor Swift.
YUFENG GUO: Only need one.
SARA ROBINSON: I only need one.
YUFENG GUO: Awesome.
So let's see.
We have our data.
It's labeled.
And I guess now there's only one
thing to do, hit the training.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah,
so training is next.
YUFENG GUO: So with all
these kind of steps,
can you just outline in how
they all connect together?
SARA ROBINSON: Mm-hmm.
So I drew about bounding
boxes around my images,
got them into the Pascal format.
And then once they're
in that format,
I wrote a script to convert them
a TFRecord, which I can then
use to feed into my model.
YUFENG GUO: Gotcha.
OK, so all this kind of steps,
now they're all connected.
You've gone from
the raw image to a--
well, not just a labeled image,
but specifically, TFRecords.
It's even formatted correctly.
So now we're ready for our
training, I guess, right?
And so in this case, we're going
your training on ML Engine,
it looks like.
It's on your blog post here.
How is that process?
And what did you have
to do to make that work?
SARA ROBINSON: So it was
similar to the process
I used for running
the training locally.
The main difference being I
needed to put all of my data
in Google Cloud Storage and
tell ML Engine where to find it.
So the first thing I needed
to get in Google Cloud Storage
was the model checkpoints
from the pre-trained model
I was using.
I used a model called
MobileNets, which is optimized
for mobile, obviously.
So I put those checkpoints
in my Cloud Storage bucket.
I also needed my training
and test TFRecord files,
which I talked about before
how I generated those.
And then I have a
config file, which
tells the Object Detection
API where my training and test
data is located.
And it supports ML Engine
and Google Cloud Storage.
YUFENG GUO: Great, great.
And so that whole thing kind
of comes together and, I guess,
just takes care of all
training for you then?
SARA ROBINSON: Mm-hmm.
YUFENG GUO: Awesome.
Then how long did that
training time take?
Everyone wants to know
if the training takes
a long time, or a little
time, and how long you
had to wait for that.
SARA ROBINSON: I think
it took about 30 minutes.
YUFENG GUO: 30 minutes,
OK, that's not too bad.
SARA ROBINSON: Not too long.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah, given what
you're getting out of it,
that's quite nice.
SARA ROBINSON: Exactly.
YUFENG GUO: So once
training is done,
what do you have kind
of as your result?
What do you have in your hand?
SARA ROBINSON: So you
have a model checkpoint,
which is just a binary file.
Similar to the pre-trained
model checkpoint
that I used to
start training, this
is now going to
be the final model
checkpoint, which
has been updated
with all of my training data.
YUFENG GUO: Gotcha, OK.
So that's very nice.
And then I guess
we now kind of flip
it over the wall to
the serving side.
SARA ROBINSON: So to serve
it, I can use gcloud command
with ML Engine to
deploy my model.
I just need to point it at
where those checkpoint files are
of my final trained model.
And then in just a
couple of minutes,
I have my model
available for serving.
And I can use that to generate
predictions against the model.
YUFENG GUO: Fantastic.
And so I guess this
kind of brings us
to the next phase
of this project.
Here we've gone from our data.
We've pre-processed it.
We've done the training.
And we have this kind
of API that can serve up
predictions at scale.
SARA ROBINSON: Exactly.
YUFENG GUO: So now we're
ready to call that endpoint.
And what did you end up
kind of architecting here?
It looks like you have
a couple of pieces.
SARA ROBINSON: Mm-hmm.
It's using a couple of
different Firebase SDKs.
So the client is a Swift app.
It's an iOS app that's
written in Swift.
And it's a pretty thin client.
So all the client is
doing is it's uploading
an image to Firebase Storage.
YUFENG GUO: Oh, OK, so that's
what that arrow is for.
SARA ROBINSON: Exactly.
And then we're using
the Firebase SDK
for Cloud Functions.
So a function is triggered
whenever an image is uploaded
to a specific storage bucket.
YUFENG GUO: Ah, very handy.
SARA ROBINSON: So the function
is written in Node.js.
And that function does a
bunch of different things.
It downloads the image.
Then it resizes it.
It base64 encodes it, which will
prepare it for the ML Engine
online prediction request.
YUFENG GUO: OK.
SARA ROBINSON: So I make
that prediction request.
If the confidence that I get
back is greater than 70%--
that's just a threshold
that I've chosen--
I'm going to draw a
box around that image.
YUFENG GUO: OK,
in the box drawing
is it looks like it's happening
here in your Node code.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah,
I'm doing that using
ImageMagick, which is available
in Google Cloud Functions.
YUFENG GUO: Oh, perfect,
very convenient.
And so then, once
the box is drawn,
how do you get that information
back to your client then?
SARA ROBINSON: So
once the box is drawn,
I write the image
to Firebase Storage.
And then I also write
some metadata on the image
to Cloud Firestore,
which is a database.
So I'm writing the
confidence of the detection
along with the path of the
image in Firebase Storage.
YUFENG GUO: Gotcha.
So that's why you kind of have
these two write operations
coming from your Cloud Function?
SARA ROBINSON: Exactly.
And the reason I'm using
Firestore is, in my client,
I can create a listener on
the ID of that image path.
And so then I get
updates whenever
new data has been added to
that collection in Firestore
so I don't have to keep pulling
that to see if the detection is
finished.
So right when it's finished,
my client will get an update.
And then I can then
download the new image
with the box around it, along
with the confidence detection
score.
YUFENG GUO: So
that's really neat
that you've managed to use
the kind of architecture
to signal in both directions.
You upload to Cloud
Storage, and that
triggers the Cloud Function.
So on upload, something happens.
And it happens right away.
And then coming back, once
the response from ML Engine
is received, you're using
Firestore to basically give
that real time update to hit
your phone right away, as well.
So you kind of keep
that loop tight,
even though you managed
to do that while all
the while maintaining
this kind of thin client.
That's really nice,
the way you've
kind of leveraged the
existing technology.
You didn't have
to write anything
to make sure everything happened
nice and quick, but async.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, one thing
that's great about Firebase
is I get those real
time updates whenever
new data comes in that path.
YUFENG GUO: Fantastic.
So I guess, zooming
out a little bit,
you've built the mobile
app that builds a custom
machine learning model.
You've collected your own data.
You've annotated it.
You're training and
you're serving at scale
to your mobile client.
What did you find to be kind
of the most interesting part
of all of this?
SARA ROBINSON: I
would say, definitely
learning to tie together
all these different tools.
So there's a lot
of different things
I used to build the
app, from [INAUDIBLE],,
from TensorFlow
Object Detection,
to Cloud Machine
Learning Engine, which
has a couple of
different components
that had training, serving
and online prediction.
And then the client piece using
some Swift SDKs and Firebase
SDK for Cloud Functions.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah.
And just along the way, you're
hitting Python, Node, Swift,
Java--
well, JavaScript is there.
SARA ROBINSON: Even
a little bit of bash
with the gcloud commands.
YUFENG GUO: That's right.
Outstanding.
And so, on the
whole, what did you
find to be most challenging
out of all of this?
SARA ROBINSON: The
most challenging part
was getting all of the data
into Google Cloud Storage.
Because there was a
lot of different pieces
that need to be there, from the
pre-training model checkpoints,
the TFRecords, and
then that config file,
which tells Object
Detection where
to find these different pieces.
YUFENG GUO: Right.
And these are all coming
kind of from different places
and just getting
it all arranged.
Yeah, I could see how
that could be challenging.
And was there some fun parts, as
well, hopefully, along the way?
SARA ROBINSON: It was.
It was pretty fun to build.
One thing that was
kind of funny was
I label all the images myself.
So there was a day where I--
YUFENG GUO: Hard work.
SARA ROBINSON: I know.
It was a tough job.
So there was a day
where I had pictures
of Taylor Swift on my computer.
People who walked
by were probably
wondering what I was doing.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah, just
perusing photos all day.
SARA ROBINSON:
Exactly, generating
those bounding boxes.
And the most fun thing was
definitely the final result
of seeing on the iOS
app the prediction
with the bounding box
come back in real time.
YUFENG GUO: Definitely,
yeah, that's a long journey.
SARA ROBINSON: Mm-hmm.
It was.
YUFENG GUO: Awesome.
And as I understand, you've
actually open-sourced your code
on GitHub.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, it's all
available on my personal GitHub
repo.
And there's instructions
in the readme
if you want to build
the same model yourself.
YUFENG GUO: Awesome.
That's so great that our
audience can go out and build
their own model.
And I want to thank you so much.
I really appreciate
you coming in today
and chatting in the studio.
SARA ROBINSON:
Thanks for having me.
Great to be here.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah,
it's been great.
Thanks for watching this episode
of "Cloud AI Adventures."
Today, we saw how
to go from raw data,
to training, to a mobile client.
You can use Sara's GitHub
repo to not only recreate
this, but extend it with your
own data, a different model,
or a different client app.
For more details,
we've included links
to all the resources we
discussed in the description.
So check it out.
And if you've enjoyed this
episode, please like it
and subscribe to get
more episodes right
when they come out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BEEP]
SARA ROBINSON: So the
Object Detection API
is more of a series of--
sorry, I'm going to redo that.
[BEEP]
YUFENG GUO: What does it
take to build a custom image
recognition-- no.
[BEEP]
SARA ROBINSON: Custom
object recognition.
[BEEP]
YUFENG GUO: What does it take
to build a custom recog--
[BEEP]
A custom object
recognition mobile app.
[BEEP]
I don't know what to do next.
[LAUGHING]